in five years how much can a country
change Tunisia has seen off a despot
inspired revolution across a continent
and despite being the victim of
terrorist attacks by is in his manager
State on the Democratic path the
President of the European Parliament
Martin Schulz has been unofficial visit
to the country he paid homage to the
victims of the Bardo Museum terrorist
attack in Tunisia in March last year in
a passive way no Latin in Seattle
received the terrorist jihadist Pascal
model citizen Sochi till the contrary
circular companies repair and devour
uncontrollable copper Arabic Latin easy
and part of that cooperation included a
full meeting with the prime minister of
Tunisia
habiba seed in 2013 Tunisian like other
Arab Spring Nations teetered on the
brink of Civil War before civil society
groups uniting under the banner of a
civil society quartet drew up an action
plan to state initiative democracy
president Schulz also met with a quartet
who awarded the 2015 Nobel Peace Prize
but possibly to news his biggest problem
is turning around their economy the
sector touristic a come on darlin emoji
new for the ho dress a tourism that
accounted for 6.5 percent of GDP was
shattered following a deadly ice attack
on hotel beach ensues not led a
coccolithophores Aldo de Luca special
only they are seesaw when set yong-ho
become Fierro tell a it fear me